as action flicks and superhero
blockbusters continue to dominate the
box office
we're finally getting the strong female
leaves we've been lacking for decades in
both film and TV the physical demands of
these roles are no joke
but these actresses were more than up
for the challenge let's take a look at
some of the amazing women who put in
maximum effort in order to kick ass on
screen Alison Bray until recently
Alison Brie was best known for playing a
long-suffering wife on Mad Men a role
that required serious acting skills but
no stunt work so when she landed a
starring role on Netflix original series
glow she had to train like a mad woman
to get a literal fighting shape
sometimes that meant intense workouts
when she hold weighted objects onto the
gym floor other times it meant carrying
a 220 pound trainer Jason Walsh around
the room on her back Walsh said his goal
for the training regimen was to turn
Brie into someone who could both dish
out and take a hit he told a business
insider Alison did all the stunts I'll
tell you right now I've worked with a
lot of people and she's a little badass
Alyssia vikander prior to her
preparation for the role of adventure
junkie lara croft and the tomb raider
reboots Alicia vikander told the Graham
Norton Show me I'd never lifted a thing
with my arm not one thing to disappoint
fans for cons I hit the gym harder than
ever for four months
the Oscar winner ended up adding 10 to
12 pounds of muscle but this new and
improved physique would be short-lived
it takes three weeks for you to lose it
all yeah [ __ ] Lupita Nyong'o someone
forgot to tell the PETA Tiago you're not
supposed to enjoy boot camp she took
part in a six-week session along with a
black panther co-stars sometimes working
out as early as 3:00 a.m. for as long as
four hours and called the intensive
experience fun
Nyong'o told Collider she enjoyed
challenging her body saying I get to
jump higher than I thought I could jump
I get to roll backwards which I thought
I would never do after the age of 8 so
it's been fun the younger was already a
workout enthusiasts but the exercising
and dieting for Black Panther took her
fitness to a whole other level she told
The Hollywood Reporter I remember coming
home for Christmas and I couldn't fit
into my clothes margot robbie director
craig Gillespie brought up skating
scenes in a Tonya using both CGI and
stunt doubles but not all of Margot
Robbie's scenes involved Hollywood magic
she trained on the ice
three times a week for three months and
learned five routines and all Robbie
told Wonderland of our intense training
my alarm would go off at 5:30 a.m. and
I'd want to cry
sometimes after sessions I'd get back
into the car and weep those tears of
frustration eventually turned into tears
of joy
Robbie's performance as the disgraced
skater earned her an Oscar nomination
Emma Stone trainer Jason Walsh has an
Instagram photo of a feeble Emma Stone
with a caption that reads deadlift PR
day change takes breaking comforts and
states that stone was prepping for a
role in battle of the sexes he told W
Magazine when she trained for lala land
we worked out three to four days a week
with battle of the sexes we did five
days a week and sometimes two times a
day stone trained for three months and
put on 15 pounds of muscle for the role
she seemed giddy with the results
telling CNN it was the first time I'd
ever felt like oh my god I can lift a
lot of weight you feel like the Hulk a
little bit there was the first time that
I focused so so much on the physicality
of someone because playing an athlete
that is the way that she was able to
make change in the world Rooney Mara it
wasn't enough for Rooney Mara to get
multiple piercings for her role in The
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo she was
determined to go all-in which for her
meant training a wide variety of fields
she told MTV I feel like I went to
school I had motorcycle class from 9 to
11 and then I went the dialect class and
then I had skateboarding and then I had
computer training and then I had
kickboxing
she told The Hollywood Reporter the
skateboarding was the sort of try and
changed the way that I walk and stand
the kickboxing was meant to help her
feel confident taking a close-up
on-screen she told parade the character
is incredibly comfortable in her
sexuality and I had to go in making the
film feeling the same way thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love team
[Music]